can you talk us through how you make a
beat sheet I don't I I i will if
contractually obliged doing a beat sheet
or an outline i will do it and sometimes
you are and what usually happens is you
spend all this time on this beat sheet
in this outline and it's the most
bastardize thing in the world because
it's not a script it's not a story it's
kind of this thing that exists halfway
between a script and a story and i will
but i will do it if contractually
obliged to i'll do an outline and i'll
do a very detailed outline and i'll do
it
always to the best of my abilities I
won't slum but I'll do it and I'll hand
it in and the producers will go we love
this outline this is a great outline now
go write the script and you'll go write
the script and you'll have your outline
you'll say okay here's what the outline
is telling me and you'll start writing
and it will immediately start changing
and better ideas will emerge and the
next thing you know the outline is
completely out the window and you've
written a script and you'll turn it in
and the producers will go we love this
this is just like the outline and
everyone's forgotten the outline and and
I don't I know again my Beach it is I
obviously you kind of know the beginning
you know you're putting your characters
and you feel these characters and you
put them in this situation that they're
gonna have to fight for their lives to
get out of I kind of know what the end
is gonna be kind of sort of and then
it's the great unknown and to do that in
a beat sheet to me it's just taking all
the fun out of it so don't don't don't
listen to me listen to all the other
people out there who say outline beat
sheets please if that's what you need to
do and there's great writers who do that
of course they do that but and and
sometimes when you're collaborating it
becomes more necessary because you're
sending stuff back and forth but for me
I I they don't work for me and at any
time I do them everything starts
changing
anyway so much that that they quickly
become irrelevant why don't they work
for you because that because I'm a
storyteller and and the stories emerge
from someplace that that that is Beach
heatproof that's just me yeah I don't
know what I mean they just they just
come from somewhere else and if I tell
it all in in a quote-unquote beachy it's
like it's like why why would I do that
to myself why would I why would I take
all the fun out of discovering it and
put it in this thing that's just kind of
bullet points it's just but that's me
that and and that's the idiosyncratic
part of me but I'm in good company
Stephen King my favorite writer asked
him about beat sheets there's it but but
you know help me the writer who wrote
Game of Thrones the books thank you he
said at the best of anyone he said there
are now you would think particularly if
you've read the Game of Thrones books
that those things are outlined
completely they're so intricate they're
so full of plot and character and this
needs to overlap and this needs to you
know I mean that they're extremely
intricate stories he doesn't outline and
what he says about it is and I think
it's such a great quote and I'm
paraphrasing a little bit but it's the
essence of it
there are architects and there are
gardeners an architect will need that
blueprint to build what it is they're
going to build he said I'm a gardener I
plant a seed and I tended and nurse it
and I watch it grow and there are
architects who will do that beat sheet
and will do it brilliantly and and I'm
so I'm not knocking it and then there
are gardeners and I guess I'm
gardener I just kind of let the idea it
there and I tended at night and I take
good care of it and make sure it gets
all the water and Sun and I watch it
grow
you